[Musique]
le marin shadow qui est arrivé à
l'endroit du cosmos où il n'y a plus
d'eau il avance quand même mais comment
c'est qu'en ce temps-là on pouvait aller
en bateau dans le cosmos à condition
d'en porter son nom
[Musique]
mais malheureusement par endroits le
cosmos était percé le long fatalement on
en perdait et quand il n'y avait plus
d'eau ont sombré pour la remplacer il
fallait apporter d'énormes provisions
d'eau et souvent il y avait plus d'eau
dans le bateau que sous le bateau si
bien qu'il y avait des shadoks qui
périssent noyés 100 m que le bateau
coule
c'était pas très confortable mais
c'était pourtant comme ça que les mains
shadoks avancé elle croyait ces naïve
bête traverser tout l'espace
interstellaire est débarqué chez les
gibiers en catimini pour leur voler leur
fusée mais il y a longtemps que les
jubilés voyez venir et ils avaient
décidé de leur jouer un tour pour que
les malheureux marin continue à ramer
comme ça pendant toute l'éternité et
même peut-être plus
[Musique]